oh it looks like I'm talking to predator
I think we communicate very well
Oh excellent communication
how did with that that wasn't a real
sentence I like best friends and we
always like nobody each other's thinking
I can just look into her eyes and and I
know and we're taking I know he's that
no I think I'm gonna do better I'm sorry
I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna draw a lot
I'm gonna drill so much it's gonna be
drool city you just rolled in your sleep
loss of it I don't tell me but that
looks like you're at a dentist's office
ah ah garlic yeah girl protection engage
[Laughter]
all right crafty sure what a crafty sir
here's her blossom blow out her ass or
no a hair late old rifle huh okay yeah
like oh I am I'm not talented truth I do
total actress I need a towel playful
nose lying like hang like sitting yes
but an Aston here got it
look for soon got though are you
Lucca seen somebody steamed up the wazoo
no okay hey my little dog Oh her hers
perfect peanuts
[Applause]
her speed Bestine vessel st my Biffle
dog no my Biffle Bob prefers perfect
peanuts if questions occurred ari Hait
ask questions before lying yeah
alright Josh are you okay
marah's vows are secretly broken uh yeah
it's your voice in there blimey tiny
fighting
okay I need Oh bye-bye shrinking me free
Clinton yeah like ya doing it a lot like
like I have to always support you now
funny love babies - white chrysanthemums
crush person on hmm yes this Creek this
was a lot harder than I expected I feel
like they did okay I feel like we
crushed it hey yeah I wasn't expecting
to drool and have my lips chapped at the
same time you can't hear her
[Music]